Have you ever wondered what makes up a tooth?
The two main parts of the tooth are the crown and the root.
The crown is the white part of the tooth you can see.
The root is unseen below the gumline.
Each tooth is made up of four different tissues:...
...enamel, dentin, pulp and cementum.
Enamel, one of the hardest parts of your body, covers the crown...
...and protects the tooth from everyday use.
Dentin is the softer layer which supports the enamel and helps absorb pressure from eating.
At the center of the tooth is the pulp.
Pulp nourishes the tooth and houses nerves and blood vessels.
And lastly, covering the root is the cementum.
The cementum helps attach a tooth to the jawbones.
Good oral health care and regular dental visits...
...help to keep all parts of your smile healthy and beautiful.
For the ADA Dental Minute, I'm Dr. Maria Lopez Howell.